ONE-LINERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME TONIGHT.
AS BIDEN STRUGGLES, AMERICA'S
ENEMIES ARE BECOMING INVOLVED
IN.
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S TAUNTING AND
THREATENING THE UNITED STATES.
CHINA'S DICTATOR RIGHT NOW IS
HURLING A FEW VIOLENT THREATS OF
HIS OWN, HE DOESN'T WANT TO BE
LEFT OUT.
THE CCP WILL PROBABLY NEVER TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE VIRUS
THEY UNLEASHED ON THE WORLD.
ACCORDING TO ONE NEW REPORT, A
TOP RESEARCHER AT THE WUHAN
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY HAS
DECIDED CHINESE MILITARY.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO HOLD THE
MALIGNANT COMMUNIST PARTY OF
CHINA ACCOUNTABLE?
JENNY ME KNOW,
SENATOR TOM COTTON.
THANKS FOR JOINING ME.
>> GOOD TO BE ON WITH YOU.
>> Dan: YOU ARE ONE OF THE
VOICES, YOU ARE ATTACKED
GROTESQUELY ATTACKED FOR
SPEAKING TRUTH EARLY ON AND
ASKING BASIC QUESTIONS.
THERE'S A LAB IN WUHAN THAT
STUDIES CORONA VIRUSES, WE HAVE
A CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK THAT HAD
SAFETY PROBLEMS IN THE PAST.
HE SAID, MAYBE WE SHOULD ASK
THEM QUESTIONS.
YOU WERE BRUTALLY ATTACKED.
I KNOW YOU'RE NOT ONE OF THESE
SHOUTING GUYS, BUT IT'S GOT TO
BE FEELING GOOD TO BE RIGHT.
THEY LOOK LIKE IDIOTS NOW.
>> I WISH I HAD BEEN WRONG,
OBVIOUSLY GIVEN ALL OF THAT THE
AMERICANS HAVE LOST OVER THE
LAST 18 MONTHS FROM THIS
PANDEMIC, BUT IT DIDN'T TAKE A
LOT OF INTELLIGENCE TO SAY, THIS
VIRUS EMERGE FROM WUHAN, RIGHT
DOWN THE STREET FROM WHERE THE
RESEARCH VIRUSES.
MAYBE WE SHOULD TAKE A LOOK AT
THEM.
I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT NBC NEWS IS
FINALLY REPORTING TO ITS VIEWERS
THAT THAT LAB HAS DEEP TIES TO
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY'S
MILITARY.
IF YOU'RE WATCHING FOX 18 MONTHS
AGO AND EVER SINCE, YOU WOULD
KNOW THAT.
THERE'S NO DISTINCTION IN CHINA
BETWEEN THE PARTY AND THE STATE
AND THE MILITARY, AND SUPPOSEDLY
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS LIKE
GOVERNMENT RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS
OR COMPANIES OR ANYTHING ELSE.
TO THE PARTY CONTROLS
EVERYTHING, AND THE MILITARY IS
THE ARM OF THE COMMUNIST PARTY
IN CHINA.
>> Dan: SENATOR, I HAD FORMER
DNI JOHN RATCLIFFE ON MY SHOW
LAST WEEK, AND ASK HIM THIS
QUESTION, I WILL ASK YOU.
IT FEELS LIKE WE'RE LOSING COME
HERE.
I MEAN, CHINA'S INFILTRATED
HOLLYWOOD, OUR SPORTS INDUSTRY
AND WE HAVE TECHNOLOGY
TAKEOVERS.
WE'VE HAD GOVERNMENT SECUREMENT
ISSUES IN CHINA, INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY THEFT.
WE HAVE TAIWAN BEING THREATENED,
WE HAVE HONG KONG IN THE MIDST
OF A TAKEOVER RIGHT IN FRONT OF
OUR FACES.
I MEAN, WHAT CAN WE DO?
IS THERE ANY WAY TO EXPAND WHERE
WE CAN SANCTION SOME OF THE
DIPLOMATS MUST MAKE THE ONE
THING THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO
IS VISIT AMERICA, BUT LISTEN,
I'M A PATRIOT LIKE YOU, BUT WE
GOT TO BE CANDID.
IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE WE ARE
TAKING A KICK IN THE COONEY'S.
WE GOT TO FIGHT BACK.
>> POLITICIANS IN BOTH PARTIES
FOR MANY DECADES PUT CHINA'S
INTERESTS AHEAD OF SO MANY
AMERICANS AND TRUSTS.
WHETHER IT'S OUR FACTORY
WORKERS, OR STATION IN THE
WESTERN PACIFIC.
AT SOME OF THE MISSIONARIES IN
CHINA, HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THEIR OWN PEOPLE.
WHETHER COMMITTING AGAINST
ETHNIC MINORITIES.
CHINA NEEDS US A LOT MORE THEN
WE NEED THEM.
WE CAN BUY YOUR T-SHIRTS AND
SEEKERS AND OTHER COUNTRIES.
ARE THEY GOING TO SELL THEIRS?
WE CAN TAKE THINGS AWAY FROM
COMMUNIST OFFICIALS AND THEIR
KIDS.
IT SHOULD BE FOR AMERICAN KIDS.
WE CAN INVOKE THEIR PERMIT MOST
FOR PERMANENT NATION STATUS.
RATHER, CONGRESSMEN TO DECIDE
EVERY YEAR WHETHER WE WILL
DECIDE TO EXTEND IT FOR ANOTHER
YEAR.
WE COULD MAKE THEM PAY FOR
UNLEASHING THE SPIKE ON THE
WORLD ALSO FOR DECADES OF LYING
AND CHEATING AND STEALING.
IT'S TIME TO LOWER THE BOOM ON
CHINA.
>> Dan: IT SEEMS, SENATOR LIKE
THE ONLY COUNTRY DOING IT RIGHT
NOW IS AUSTRALIA.
AUSTRALIA IS TAKING A PRETTY
MUSCULAR STAND.
I WANT TO MOVE ON QUICKLY TO
RUSSIA, BECAUSE THAT'S
IMPORTANT, TOO.
YOU WILL WELL-VERSED IN FOREIGN
POLICY.
WHAT AN EMBARRASSMENT THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN STOPS A
PIPELINE, HERE, THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE, COSTING AMERICANS
11,000 JOBS.
THEN HE GIVES VLADIMIR PUTIN A
FREE PASS TO BUILD A PIPELINE TO
ENRICH THEMSELVES STRAIGHT TO
GERMANY WHEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TRIES TO STOP
THIS BECAUSE OF THE TRANSIT FEES
THEY WOULD'VE BYPASSED.
I MEAN, I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
DEMOCRATS UP ON THE HILL WITH
YOU SEE THAT AS BEING FAIR.
BLOCK A PIPELINE HERE, BUT GIVE
IT TO RUSSIA?
>> IT'S CRAZY, DAN, THAT WE
WOULD END A PIPELINE HERE,
THAT'S HAVING STOMACH PAYING
THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN JOBS,
WHILE JOE BIDEN ALLOWS A
PIPELINE TO BE BUILT FROM RUSSIA
TO GERMANY, TO MORE DEEPLY HOOK
WESTERN EUROPE ON RUSSIAN GAS,
AND TO PREVENT AMERICANS FROM
EXPORTING OUR GAS TO WESTERN
EUROPE, WHERE WE COULD CREATE
EVEN MORE JOBS HERE.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE THIRD
PIPELINE, IT WAS RUSSIAN
CRIMINALS THAT HACKED INTO THE
COLONIAL PIPELINE THAT CAUSED
GAS LINES ALL ACROSS THE EASTERN
UNITED STATES.
JOE BIDEN'S ANEMIC RESPONSE TO
THEM DID NOTHING TO TEACH
VLADIMIR PUTIN A LESSON THAT
THEY CANNOT CONTINUE TO HARBOR
THE CYBER CRIMINALS THAT
CONTINUE TO ATTACK AMERICA'S
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE GAS
PIPELINES OR MEAT PROCESSING
PLANTS.
THE ONLY THING VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
LEARNING OF THE LAST SIX MONTHS
IS THAT UNCLE SAM IS WEARING A
KICK ME SIGN WITH JOE BIDEN IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Dan: THAT'S A GREAT WAY TO
SUM UP THE LAST SIX MONTHS,
UNFORTUNATELY I'M OUT OF TIME,
THANKS F